[Musik]
hallo hallo zusammen so sullivan
heute gibt ein richtig tolles und vor
allem schnelles rezept wir werden
nämlich eine bohne machen und vor allem
seine app oder komplett ohne alkohol und
es ist wirklich der perfekte
durstlöscher gerade an warmen tagen und
vor allem zuerst derzeit das land habe
ich so fein dass mit waldmeister was
meister bekommt er in kuba für den
supermärkten oder auch im bau mars oder
vielleicht auch in so einem kleinen
garten marken gemüsemarkt in eurem ort
dann ist da einfach nur nachschauen wie
sage ich jetzt mal ganz frische zutaten
auf jeden fall finden symbole richtig
perfekt sind zum beispiel mit daten
party macht oder ein geburtstag feiert
oder ich einfach ko nachmittags oder
abends mit euren freunden treffen und
sie ist wirklich super gut vorzubereiten
einfache zutaten und vor allem sehr
lecker und eine rutsche war habe ich nur
die besten wo nur freuen was natürlich
muss das ist im falle von finde ich
immer recht cool und vor allem kann man
auch immer nehmen was gerade da hat
unser zeitalter wolle
und ich sage ich mal kurz hier vorne
sitzt taten folgen
am flughafen brauche ich sechs esslöffel
braunem zucker saft von drei bis vier
betonen etwas frischem waldmeister auf
750 gramm erdbeeren 500 milliliter
apfelsaft um später brauchte nur einen
liter kaltes mineralwasser zuerst mal
nehme ich jetzt den braunen zucker und
gebt ihn einfach mal in mein bruder
gefällt da habe ich mir wirklich vor
vier oder fünf jahren wartet die pole
gefehlt irgendwann mal geholt
aber ihr könnt auch ganz einfach eine
ganz große schüssel nehmen was ihr
einfach gehabt und es hier rein geben
brauchen besucher nämlich ganz gerne
weil der regisseur dem tisch ist um
wirklich sehr gut schmeckt aber auch
kunden von zucker müsste die polin
natürlich auch schon ganz viel
herstellen und schon ziehen lassen
damit das auch gut auftreten kann dann
nehme ich jetzt wie zitronen und werde
jetzt auspressen und dem dach direkt
eingeben
ich hatte noch nie so viele unserer
aufbauen ein kabel verbindet mailbox der
praxen durch die zitrone auch über so
sehr genauso gnädig immer sind drei
maskierte und dann geht es auch viel
besser und zitronen auch immer bei
zimmertemperatur lagern und dann lassen
sie sich wirklich super aus bretten
vor allem riecht schon sehr gut also ich
weiß jetzt schon hier wurde zutaten hier
stehen weil sie jetzt schon wie die
boote später schmeckt man aufgrund
dessen wir haben ja schon angetrunken
aber auch eben allein von dem geruch was
uns verbindet auf jeden fall
und auch beim zu crysis oder mit einfach
selber abstimmung wie viel unternehmens
wenn die app dann wirklich schon richtig
schön system könnte auch mit weniger
zucker nehmen oder auch generell sind
wir das nicht so ganz möchte aber so
kann ich eigentlich von das ist daher
wirklich sehr perfekt und keinen brown
dann nimmt man ganz neue weise zucker
oder auch zum beispiel zucker erfasst
also man kann ja auch zum beispiel
kokosnüssen zucker nehmen oder agaven
weg sagt das geht auch alles auf jeden
fall
wenn du vom rad immer gern als der jung
also als spielmaschine
zitronen oder auch ein bisschen
verrühren
merkt ihr auch das hat sich nicht so
auflösen deswegen das ganze eben gleich
auch ein bisschen steht jetzt nämlich
waldmeister da muss ich dazu sagen dass
ich auch dass ich zum ersten mal
weltmeister china handhabe denn ich
dachte früher immer dass ich irgendwann
kunst aromastoffe ja aber irgendwie war
ramponiert ist er wirklich eine pflanze
die existiert und wir planten wird auch
unseren garten ein und gericht so die
richter wenn man dran riecht ein
spanischer stark nach wald meister bis
aroma entfaltet sich dann wirklich erst
und deswegen geht man das auch jetzt
schon hier mit symbole dazu und wenn man
kauft und schmeckt auch bitter account
würde ich nicht wo aber wie gesagt gibt
es auch immer ganz toll an den sirup
hier gleich ab dann kann man alternativ
zweitmeisten sirup nehmen oder einfach
auch weglassen und das ganze mit
limetten zum beispiel auf bundes- geht
auch automatisch bei ist hier wirklich
zum tag x vor
bohle deluxe würde gefangen und besucher
wirklich zu verlängern
ich kann jetzt schon mal ein bisschen
ziehen und es werden die erdbeeren vom
grünen befreien vierteln und dann hier
mit reingeht
[Musik]
kann ich das ganze bestimmt und so habe
ich jetzt schon mal die basis geschaffen
und führen jetzt hier auch den apfelsaft
gleich mit rein und dann muss das ganze
für mindestens drei stunden ziehen
je länger ihr das im kühlschrank ziehen
lasst umso intensiver wird auch der
geschmack vor allem der geschmack von
waldmeister
[Musik]
mehr
die folie ist es richtig schön
durchgezogen und jetzt kurz vor dieser
werden kommt einfach noch kaltes
mineralwasser ist so ein lied aus
[Musik]
und jetzt schon so die pole schon
serviert werden
hier haben wir zu viert angerichtet und
ich hab das ganze auf ein viertel unter
wert ist oder schön kalt aber ich finde
das ist doch mal ein bisschen abbrechen
da morath mich zu probieren
ja ich war ja ganz gut findet dass man
immer auch eine detaillierte bewertung
spies leser und wir haben heute auch
noch voll mit gästen aus der schweiz
waltraud gelb
probier doch mal dein glück genau jeden
fall bin ich auch getränke erfrischend
war lecker den sirup könnte glatt von
supergut ansetzen und dann einfach mit
dem wasser aufgießen und fertig sehr
erfrischend oder und im prinzip auch
wieder fahren kann und angaben kann egal
weil wir das gerne nachmachen möchte
dann schaut auf meinem blog vorbei auf
der leeze wenn das paket das jetzt noch
mal ganz genau und ich wünsche euch eine
gute steckt viel spaß danach machen
worauf wir aber noch davon
bis zum nächsten mal sehen uns ja genau
egal kann jeden treffen
wenn du möchtest die ganze schweiz die
schweizer zuschauer und seien ganz
empfehlen die begrüßung vor allem an die
max eberl liebe emma und den simon auf
der schweiz nämlich auch zwei zuschauer
[Musik]